back to I should have about enough money
right now to actually finish this roller
coaster because I just want to do
something and then I left the game on
playing and I was like yeah money when I
came back so I was making fat stacks
year and yeah good life so raise or
lower land first okay um how do I do
that again like I know how I do that but
how do I do this without making it look
weird I could go here and then do
something with that hmm i don't know
this is actually pretty hard because i
only have this space to come out of this
terraforming while this underground
position that I'm in right now but it's
going to be hard to go back to the
station and wait as bend and I guess
we'll just go up over here hey that
should work oh we're underneath that
square oops I didn't do anything oh I'm
afraid I'm going to have to lower three
tiles for this oh wait I am I'm
terraforming the wrong square while that
goes all my money great I'm such an
idiot when it comes to stuff like this
okay so that's not going to work going
to have to lower it just a bit more and
then it should work let me see yes thank
you
so we're going to go back into the
station like that well that's not too
bad hmm and what if it actually makes it
but if it will this is going to be one
hell of a good ride oh that's the law of
cars let's see five trains five trains
with three I mean three trains with five
cars per train that's very good now
let's see if it actually does make it
because that's very important and in the
meanwhile actually in the meanwhile in
the meantime actually do these things
yeah bro and that should be all good
wait this thing is still default and
what's with this and of course i'm going
to change the colors because they're not
really good right now so yeah it's a
pretty fast ride but then again it's not
that intense has a pretty decent speed
actually a very small lift cell it's not
that big of a ride after all actually go
down over there and up again yeah the
pacing is pretty good and of course you
have that little fast part on the ground
and i don't think i really need the
brakes at the end so i think i'm just
going to keep it without brakes and
really the only thing that I really risk
is my comment section going mad again
but I don't care so I'm going to open it
this ride is going to be called pink
floyd because i don't know that's not
how you write floyd what are we doing ok
beautiful and pink floyd need some kind
of network i really don't have what to
do with this like I would have liked to
put some Egyptian scenery over here but
can't do that because this is a that
scenario where you can't do that I think
this is actually that game where I can't
do that so now I am pretty sure that
there are scenarios where you do have
Egyptian scenery yeah you do
you're like that not one pyramid
scenario but that's something point
under time that's a story for another
time for an episode something if I
actually continue okay so more of these
things because I don't know why I just
want stuff okay i'm sorry i'm placing
too much foliage on this desert but
dubai we've got oil year so i can do
this oh wait i still need to change that
I don't like the way that looks and we
need some hedges is nice hell yeah oh I
can't do that though well nevermind then
I will add some hedges on top of these
things just because I always like to do
that oh yeah I don't know why I just
like the combination of terraforming and
hedges but that might just be me however
I don't like the combination of
terraforming in one way in terraforming
in another way so I'm gonna change that
there we go oh yes not look so gorgeous
plenty of fun stuff going on
but it looks cool so might as well and
this thing needs some hedges and then I
think I'm done with the hedges yeah but
it looks pretty cool and some people are
already riding it nice okay so how's the
slight doing max people on the ride is
gonna be more and admission price for
this thing 630 holy [ __ ] that is really
high especially if you compare that with
the intensity tours it is higher than
the intensity wow that is very very good
Oh 630 almost exported damn I'm
impressed by myself of course that I
managed to build such an amazing wide
ok that's enough crunch robbery over
there and that's how my god i don't know
if that actually looks good it's pretty
much like the bushes are sewn on some
kind of pimples of the desert well
whatever they're good-looking pimples so
might as well drinking game every time
silver it says might as well you take an
entire bucket of what gun yeah okay so
what else do we have we've courts this
is not interesting well wait what no way
it's not interested we've got a ferris
wheel might as well hey that's not a
ferris wheel oh okay there is wheel
thank you where to put this ferris wheel
on top of the hill yes yes this is
totally happening it's gonna be on top
of the hill and it's gonna be good I
think I hope so how do I do this you
know I'm just gonna build on top of the
hill like that and the exit on the side
because I do want to go on those
mountains over there this is going to be
the longest q ever I don't know if this
is a good idea I must not forget to set
the amount of rotations to one otherwise
this is going to be complete and utter
chaos and do something else like at this
little part over here usually I'd build
a chairlift over here but you know I
don't have a chairlift yet and I don't
want to wait for that so this is going
to be the ferris wheel nice I like it
and of course we've got some straight
paths going down over here so we need to
theme them in a nice way with foliage so
that's how we do that's how we do it
and some of this stuff to shame I can't
use my favorite Chinese seeders in this
kind of environment sliders broken down
hmm I wonder how a slide can break down
but I guess I'm not the only one who
went is that so I won't do that okay oh
wait there's needs are this needs a
hedge excellent haha I got it are you
still ins because the excellent twister
okay so hey this is the this is the
perfect spot for another fountain yes
fountains galore and we need another
hedge and we've got a sexy-looking hill
hmm it's pretty simple not that
expensive scenario friendly but it
doesn't look that bad either okay cool
and we can even play some ice cream over
here so why not do that scream for my
icecream okay yeah it's gonna be out its
gonna be our blood on the dance floor
shout out to all my blood on the dance
floor fans out there and some of these
benches and litter bins on this because
why not ok so how Joshi's island doing
not too bad they can be nicer still not
as strong as she was hmm maybe need some
new butt implants and we're pretty much
done when it comes to that however we
still have room and money for a junior
coaster speaking of money though I'm
running out of money but i'm ok I've got
fat stacks and super PACs I've got oil
oh yes gorgeous those screams I just
love to look at this right I don't know
i I really don't want to boast and I am
terrible at that but sometimes you just
built a ride and all you really want to
do is just look at it and just look at
those cards and yes and that's pretty
much how I feel about this ride if only
other I had something to put in the
middle that helix because you have an
empty helix you need to put some kind of
scenery in the middle of it that's just
our CD actually at work okay so this is
a pretty much Six Flags desert Six Flags
desert just looking pretty good right
now but it needs some more attractions
in the form of normally how I'm gonna
keep the normal funding I don't want to
spend too much money because I'm kind of
low on it because I can't loan [ __ ] and
already built all of this and i think is
time for a junior it goes through yeah
but this really isn't a space that's
very fit for building a roller coaster
for building anything when it comes to
that I mean we're terraforming and all
that it's not the greatest thing maybe I
should buy some land I have no clue what
else to do or look at this roller
coaster wait it's not making too much
money Pink Floyd Oh 640 now employed
really isn't making too much money maybe
it's time to build a tunnel tunnel to
the other side hmm no probably not I
mean there are plenty of people over
here that they probably just don't want
to go on it or they can't afford it
whatever
okay so this looks pretty strong wait we
still have room over here for some kind
of ride we just don't have a ride for it
hmm but we'll have a ride pretty soon in
this haunted house perfect i was uh that
was just what i was just when I was
waiting for like I've been wanting to
build a haunted house for my entire life
ha that's a dream come true yeah the
eighth of April is that going to happen
26th of March is what it's right now so
that's still going to take quite a while
hmm oh wait we are going to do this
you're gonna do this I'm gonna build a
log flume does anybody know the song I'm
we're on a log flume by rob lv it's a
very good song you should listen to it
someday okay that cost me quite a bit of
money but finally got rid of those
things and we're gonna build a lock for
him over here I'm so bad at making this
park look good beyond I don't want to do
this but I'm gonna blame it on the park
because it's and partly on myself as
well because yeah I just suck at desert
point I just wow okay so hmm um-hum no
I'm not gonna do this I'm gonna have two
drops one of which is going to be the
small drop which can be over here which
can be our small little cutesy with
seeds Rob but you always need and the
other one is going to be a big drop the
small drop is just gonna be like this no
wait like that
and then we're going to go down double
drop hell yeah we're doing this wait no
abort mission abort mission what we need
is we need to put it somewhere over here
yeah like that and then we need to do
that because we also need room for a
small curve okay so we're gonna go down
oh wait stop gonna go down and have a
little splash down have fun do that as
bend that ass band and we're gonna go up
and here it comes the big drop go to
watch out for that one there is the big
drop it's not enough cash I don't even
have enough cash to make a log flume wow
this madness no this is sparta um-hmm
this is uh this is 2008 meantime this is
prime time meantime with silver ettes
we're going to do the hamster dance in a
minute but first we're gonna enjoy this
is fighter and a bit of the balls are a
nerd and some chocolate rain because you
know some stay dry and others feel the
pain school box say it won't be here
again speaking of force run
ok so do that curve yes and it connects
yes not enough oh no the end of the
month ok we have enough cash now good
however I do want to add a little curve
in here because it just looks better
than all those straight lines yeah
that's nice ok so it's no need to test
the right like this I mean what is that
to test really just gonna add a small
hedge over here and over here as well
which you can have a fancy tree in the
middle this is the fancy tree as you all
may know more fancy to reaction and I'll
do the rest later I just decided that I
would do something with that three
because nobody ever uses the monkey tree
nobody ever I've never really seen that
thing in real life I think that has
anybody ever seen those things in real
life unless you're living in Africa or
something but I think the only occasion
we never see that thing is when playing
that game I think that's pretty much the
only thing that tree is known from the
game oh damn it i just lost the game
great and oh now i do need to get this
path from pretty much the other side of
the country that isn't really my
favorite thing to do but this thing just
leaves me no other option now this is
going to be the log flume can't i add
more than that you can't add more boats
on that case I'm just going to make the
station bigger come here big your
station thank you can I make it even
bigger no icon however I have ten boats
that should do I'm not going to give
them weird colors because that looks som
what yeah weird and I'm going to change
the queue actually because this doesn't
work I'm going to open it not test it
there's no need to test the log flume
what to see if it if it's going to make
it of course it's going to make it
Pink Floyd is broken down no they
haven't I think they are they're working
on new album with Stephen Stephen
Hawking in it yeah I thought so yeah
they were it's pretty cool okay anyway
we need hedges um is this enough yeah
this should be about enough yeah i was
about to scream more hedges but i don't
see a reason to now I now we're on the
other side of the park though I'm gonna
add a toilet now I'm not gonna add a
toilet screw that i'm not going to add a
toilet because that costs money and i'm
not going to be one of those guys pretty
being pretty much everyone who asks
money for the toilet because he I kind
of just don't want to do that okay so
that works plus you're not going to make
too much money off a toilet so why ask
money for it anyway get some of these
large things
I want loads of palm trees around this
thing because it's a log flume after all
need to kind of get that tropical
feeling now why would you even have a
log flume in the desert anyway it
doesn't make any sense and of course
some of these I haven't really used
these bushes yet so I'll give them a
shot and Nicki Minaj's broken down well
that's fortunate news I suppose haha
nice laughs and it looks good pretty
good i must say how much money is this
thing making mmm yeah it'll probably be
okay I probably shouldn't have to worry
about that and I'll just add some small
kind of time here wait and some big ones
as well some big ones nice on the park
is actually looking pretty good let's
save actually I haven't even saved yet
okay so and with that I'm going to end
this episode so thanks for watching and
see you on the next one now I think this
episode was pretty long Atticus okay why